all right uh let's move on to another
topic that we have been discussing from
time to time we put rick spielman under
the hot light in indianapolis and i said
i want you to look right in that camera
seven year anniversary of the percy
harvin trade and i want you to say
we have no intent to trade stefan diggs
and he said stefan diggs is a minnesota
viking and you said that means
absolutely nothing and here we are it
meant absolutely nothing on the same day
that the vikings extended kirk cousins
contract for two more years putting him
under contract through 2022 stefan diggs
makes it clear he wants out first he
says it's time for a new beginning on
twitter chris and then when somebody
pushed back and said oh this is all fake
he said no something's gonna happen so
it looks like with stefan diggs
something's gonna happen
yeah it certainly does uh i i know from
a few people that i trust that know the
situation that it is very real and of
course we don't need to hear anything
from me stuff on diggs is telling you
it's real you know you know one there's
there's the vikings are in a semi retool
rebuild mode right now that's one thing
we're seeing they're taking a different
approach they're rebuilding their team
in certain areas do i think it's a
little risky
yeah i do because i think the offense is
a little challenged as is anyways as you
and i talked about many times during the
year i mean it's run it's bootleg it's
screened to dalvin cook that's that's
basically what they do so to not have
dalvin cook in that i mean not to have
stefan diggs in that formula you know i
i think is a little scary for minnesota
they obviously have other plans i don't
know if they can totally
use stefan diggs talents uh to its total
capacity would be my biggest thing i
mean diggs is special
and he's special in this in this way to
me mike he can beat you on the outside
and go right by you for an 80 yard
touchdown he can catch a slant and break
a few tackles and go for a 60 yard
touchdown he also can do like the
nuanced wes welker julian edelman type
routes over the middle of the field and
the vikings offense just not that
extensive to use him all those ways so
i'm sure they're a little sick of him i
it sounds like he's a little sick of
them too
and now the big thing is just who is it
that's in the market for stefan diggs
well and that's the question and we'll
see last week he was working out in
arizona cardinals gear and you have to
wonder whether or not that's something
that the cardinals were considering
given that they traded for deandre
hopkins and the trade for de andre
hopkins would take the cardinals out of
the stephon diggs mix but look i i agree
with you he's a great player
and i think that his talents are wasted
and the cap dollars are wasted when
you've got adam thielen who is making
close to market value and here's stefan
diggs with a 14 million or so contract
and i think look i i think that if it is
going to be run the ball run the ball
run the ball and then set up play action
passes and bootlegs you you can you can
go with a younger receiver yeah you can
look to the draft look they found digs
in round five adam thielen was undrafted
they're better off taking guys late in
the draft when they try to take a first
round or it blows up in their face so
use some draft picks it's deep this year
at the receiver position they love bc
johnson they've got irv smith and kyle
rudolph at tight end they'll be fine and
they can clear out that cap face it's
not a huge net cap gain it's 1.9 million
in net cap dollars but they'll avoid a
salary this year of nearly 11 million
dollars and that's cash that can be
spent elsewhere so it feels like
that's where it's heading when i asked
rick spielman point blank he didn't say
what he could have said diggs isn't
going anywhere all he said is he's a
minnesota viking which means
that's the 2019 or the 2020 version of
we have no intent to trade percy harvin
i i think it's just a matter of time as
do you
that stefan diggs goes somewhere else so
where do you think he's gonna go well i
mean all right so here's the teams that
jump out to me right off the bat like
buffalo bills but i i would think they
gotta be call in minnesota if they know
stefan diggs is available they run a new
england type offense there with brian
dayball as an offensive coordinator got
a young quarterback got a ton of money
so that certainly would make sense they
could they could utilize all his talents
the proper way the philadelphia eagles i
mean come on we you and i talked to
howie roseman he talked about priority
number one was getting carson wentz some
help i mean this would be your guy again
he could do everything for that offense
uh there was another team i had that
jumped out to me and i'm blanking out
and i'm choking under the pressure here
and who oh las vegas raiders i mean i
would think he'd be john gruden's type
of you know cup of tea too so you know
again
okay antonio brown last year though i
mean a guy who's got a reputation for
being a little moody when things don't
go his way now he never has been
anywhere close to antonio brown county
right but we have seen we have seen i
mean last year he went awol after that
bears game he didn't show up for work
for two or three days and they they
didn't make a big deal about it because
i think maybe they were thinking about
possibly trading him then and you don't
want to flag the guy as a problem as
you're trying to strike a deal but i
don't know that gruden's going to want
to go back to that well and i know mike
mayok's not going to want to
well yeah i mean that's a fair point
you're right but you know i think the
other thing you said is let's not put
him in the class of antonio brown that
that's for sure and listen
i i mean and i mean this i got great
friends who are all top tier receivers
are a pain in the ass they're all a pain
in the ass if they don't get the ball
for two weeks and they're a number one
receiver
and they're going to complain i mean
that's just the way it goes so you know
you know they're they're the most diva
group in the nfl but i think your point
with the raiders you know is real i mean
i i get you there they might be scarred
too afraid to deal with anything like
that right now
and you know it reminds me of a story i
was told about jerry rice and i think
we've talked about this before that they
knew in the locker room when rice was
gonna grab a microphone and be a
butthole and they would get him out of
the locker room on those days the pr
staff knew it was coming they get him
out of there and the reporters are like
oh where's jerry oh he's gone because
they wanted to let him go calm down
before he said something that was going
to resonate and create headlines so the
headline is stefan diggs is going
somewhere we will find out where that
somewhere is and i'm sure the vikings
aren't happy about this because so much
for trying to be coy right chris
you got diggs coming out and saying it's
gonna happen it's like come on man give
give us a chance to try to grift
somebody here and get the best possible
deal and my guess is rick spielman's not
real happy about that well yeah i'm sure
he's not i mean i i get it and to me the
fact that diggs says it right
to me would tell me there's more than
one team involved because i don't think
you're digs you say that if you just
think it's one team and risk it on that
i don't know i'm just trying to be a
psychologist here either way
rick spillman we are on to you we got
you i know your poker face from here on
well and the other thing the last point
on this before we move on
i really wonder whether it was a
coincidence that on the same day they
extend kirk cousins that's the day diggs
says it's time for a new beginning and
i've never gotten the sense that he's
been all in with cousins we've
interviewed him and we've had the
opportunity to talk to him
before and after the interviews and
without
saying things that we shouldn't say
because it's off the record when the
microphone's not on let me just say
i think it may not be a coincidence that
on the same day cousins extends his
contract we get
this news from diggs that it's time for
a new beginning
yeah i you know i i get it there was
certainly frustration there from stefan
diggs a number of times uh over the last
two years there in minnesota so i'm
excited to see where he goes i honestly
too mike just the last thing to button
this up i just know this
i i and this is total
just i'm throwing crap on the wall to
see if it fixed it it sticks there
i know the new england patriots always
have really admired stefan diggs ever
since he came out in the draft and i do
wonder too if they're a team that's
maybe in the trade talk for a step on
diggs and if that has anything to do
with brady we'll see i'm just i'm just
throwing that out there trying to
connect up
and let me tell you i think brady is the
kind of guy that will command this
respect from stefan diggs that will get
him to not be moody from time to time
he's got the skills he's got the
leadership he's got the demeanor and i
think stefan diggs will more often than
not
be on the right side of where he needs
to be if he's around a guy like a tom
brady all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports